your micro drilling the technique so my
body is moving watch my body my centers
move I don't have to worry about the
and but I still do the body work
and I go to the other side the body work
watch out goes ba ba ba this town
is not pushing him it's keeping
connection with him
it's not that that's not where I'm
throwing I'm working with
yeah it is
inhale
excellent
as you work try to get your in half
tension free tension free once you have
a feel for the gimmick maybe get your
young head the same tension free and
it's just the pressurized Center as you
go to push consciously relax your limbs
even more when you feel his weight
okay let's
this is not the same thing hey my hand
is going to make a spiral not this so
you go like this now
absorb look at my picture my tailbone
moving in a spot like this this is not
the path spiral spiral made by my body
moving this are keeps weight off of it
but I have to absorb him in exaggerated
it more more body
okay let's try the beer airy of your
training culture you don't want to make
techniques for the common responses you
your body has a pattern to do so I'm not
going like this do you see that not
doing that it might be a valid way of
moving but it's not what we're doing
here so my my arm is going out and then
it's actually not coming this way the
biceps not being utilized this arm is
gonna go like this
and what makes it go up is that my hip
changes direction as it's going so the
arm is kind of coming in and I'm passing
it as my hip goes back you see that so I
don't I'm not going right to left and
I'm not going up and down just here now
I'm gonna change this entire
relationship apply my hand go on like
this and my hip going like that one
right hip back and now I don't lift it
they simply turn it okay not like this
you're gonna get people and you go like
that and you get whatever but you're not
learning the universal Potter
[Music]
it's the exact opposite as the universal
pattern you doing the same thing there
it is you do the other one and you can't
get there
so body there's that right and hit my
god and I'm gonna rotate my wrists and
bring my hip back in you're gonna want
to go like this that's not what I'm
doing I'm working this hand is gonna go
like this my hips are gonna change
relationship get back
this hand turns my hips change and you
can go like this this work
so I just you see my arms are not
sneaking I'm underneath then you have a
cookie oh boy so I'm gonna I am
connected to a center you see and I
projected through his head
[Music]
I'm not grabbing him twisting him and
then pushing his elbows so your first
task is to get there you see and then
will tend to do things like this your
swords keep the shape of your elbows
don't read this first move that you're
doing here is that first move - the hip
turn that bringing a cookie home so by
doing the first as young hands on both
you see and there is
the other thing you might do if you're
not doing this stuff is you shortchange
it you see and then you just find the
space in between so always when we learn
the ritual we focus in on this part okay
so that's already wrong see where I go
ahead and grab so I can't get on the
outside
do you see where my knife edge is okay
and so now I'm gonna have to cut that on
line before we even start but I you see
kind of like when I'm going to do Soto
remember boom not after not before
there's a timing so the hand times then
that's not where we touch
inside his script so my elbows stay
inside my outer rim not like that so he
go I mean and that was it watch one of
my hands touch you see how on the
outside of him okay and then that's easy
the more you tense have more friction
you're going to cause on everything so
you relax it so I don't have to do this
you see what happened to my elbows
they're outside my outer rim I said the
centerline is not filled yet so here
comes his head but oh okay see can you
come forward no you can't throw from
here I've got to go here can you come
forward no you can't come forward what
we're gonna go here Kenny comes forward
no you can't come forward you see that
and when you guys are doing your stuff
you're just going to get a whole lot of
Scotsmen so you're here
so instead of going here and then we're
gonna hit that putting him on that span
so boom so I don't even need that range
of the bow his energies hitting is that
same energy you see that I'm doing here
I'm making up with my penetration I now
break up with his penetration by not
stopping it
what if I just take this that's the
first part and take the first part and
instead of keeping him from coming in I
left him coming by moving my body out of
the way so remember how when I'm here
you can't come in you can't come in
can't come in but that first you say so
the elbow comes in and the hand goes out
but I move my body out of the way
[Music]
and I'm not moving his energy
whoo inside out it's the same thing and
then I go I move so if anything and
pushing him in the way that he's going
you see that so I'm here letting them go
by and I push it in to what she's going
Tommy don't get tempted to start doing
this keep the geometry you could do it
big you could do it small doesn't matter
it's the same
don't wait here too late
the opening already came who's opening
is right here boom boom you can do it
static slowly taking energy and
manipulating it dynamic make sure you
have the side of my dad with that
traction certify that shoots you all the
time
[Music]
so I was saying I was getting out of the
way it's probably better to understand
it I'm getting a him get out of their
way should I'm getting on the other side
of the the point of articulation of the
force okay so I am on this side of the
force and I'm going to get to the other
side of the force so that I now
harmonized that energy Hey
so the first move is the first movement
of this okay first move whoa
and now look as you see how I'm
traveling on the other side of the force
do you see that and then I can now make
her longer force so it is a
reconciliation alright and he does yin
in the sense that she's allowed to keep
her young but it becomes young because
I've been accelerated and my last point
is that as I do this the reason I can
accelerate her is manifested in my
ability to stop her so if I just get out
of the way then it's only whatever
velocity she had so as she as she goes
and she tries to stop me she can't stop
me because I'm moving her understand but
I'm not moving her in this outer deltoid
way she can't come in when you go out
her deltoid she can come in
when I go here she can't come in and
come in but I can start moving this do
you see but she still can't come in
right and then I'm going round it and I
accelerated so home here we let her pull
pull against it if I try to pull that I
can't do that but look what I'm doing
so what you're what you what feels
gentle to you and why do you think I'm
just getting out of the way is that I'm
not pulling on you you see that when I
am pushing on so to speak try to get